[Music]
[Applause]
hey hello welcome back to the break room
everybody we're so happy to have you
here uh This is Our Daily Show that
keeps you updated on the nerdy news you
need to know live from the new rock
stars break room coming up today
Superman is out of a job we're gonna be
talking about what's next for the
Superman franchise and James Gunn and
Peter saffron in DC and maybe what's
next for Henry Cavill because it ain't
gonna be playing Superman
um damn also trilogies are hard question
mark exclamation mark and we're gonna
play some very fun bang Mary kill with
some spider-verse characters oh hello
with me to do that I've got Brandon bear
Jessica Clemens koi John Dro uh a real
murderer's row of folks here today
um let's jump right into it the news
broke yesterday right after the break
room went live I think as they were
watching them a break room that's right
then they have to give the news after
that now could you imagine if James Gunn
was that spiteful and he was like wait
I'm gonna release the news after all the
shows are off uh yeah it would be the
highest compliment but um so it came out
James Gunn is writing the script for a
new Superman film that is currently in
the works this feels like the very first
project under the gun saffron uh
management of DC right like we haven't
heard of anything else that is this far
along in development this might be the
very first movie that they kind of have
their fingerprints on
um The Hollywood Reporter is saying that
it's possible he could be directing the
film so it's not confirmed that he's
directing we were just talking about
this he is writing it apparently he's
been working on it for a while
though isn't it kind of funny wouldn't
he be the one deciding who directs this
movie yes yes I know I mean they made it
sound like uh if he's if it seems like
it's the best choice for him because
they're also not telling us what else is
in what else they're playing right
they're still pitching that right now so
it's like if something else seems more
important than what they want them at
that they'll put them on that it was
very much like yeah he could direct it
sure why not he's a director but I think
it'll depend on how fleshed out The plan
is that he can let go of the steering
wheel once it moves right like the
momentum of everything because Kevin
feige couldn't direct something right
now like even if he could like even if
he was an accomplished director we
wouldn't want him going into phase five
being like let me take two years so I
don't know if James Gunn will have the
time while he's positioned in this spot
to direct right whereas writing like
once it's done obviously rewrites Etc
but once it's done you you were not on
set and it's easier to have a
collaborator there who maybe does a lot
of the writing for you as well uh so
supposedly and just to rewind right the
James good timeline of the last five
years after Guardians two bit of the
falling out a brief falling out with
Marvel or you know some Twitter Scandal
whatever that's when he travels across
Town goes and visits the folks at DC
what eventually led to him making the
suicide squad but as part of his initial
meetings with them he'd actually pitched
them a Superman film way back four years
ago with the current Administration and
so this is that same kind of pitch that
same idea uh presumably he's put more
work into it since then
um even though he's gone back to Marvel
since then and done Guardians three and
uh the holiday special
um and uh a Cavill Henry Cavill the
Superman we have known for the last
however many years the Snyder vs
Superman will not be returning as
Superman that part I guess has been
confirmed yeah because this story that
James Gunn has been working on is about
a younger Superman
a baby well not a baby Superman and he
he did confirm too that it's not an
origin story it's like it's going to be
similar to like probably like Batman
year One or Superman YouTube does it
count as an origin story if he's like a
teenager but I guess he's still well he
said he would be working it would be
like a young Clark Kent working at the
daily planet right but uh it's not it's
not like a full like man pot find a baby
in a cornfield and he's like oh look I
can run fast like I think they're taking
the Spider-Man route right the MCU
Spider-Man of like you know how we got
to this point let's just move on please
please even the most recent the mattress
Batman kind of is that he's already
beating up dudes on the street yeah but
he's not as maybe a veteran crime we got
a couple flashbacks there I forget did
we see the the pearls hit the alley oh
very consciously no pearls I wanted
Pearl watch I want to see the flowers go
up in the air I want to see the pearls
get ripped do you want to see the
matinee yeah I want to see what the
movie is always always that scene has
been played an animation and skills and
everything and I'm like I'm tired of
singing these damn pearls Amanda still
was only 10 years ago which is also
somehow already 10 years ago you're
right it's already been doing so next
year's 10 years so I think it's a good
time to kind of reposition where they're
gonna go not have an origin story again
because we've seen the pearls the
equivalent of the pearls being the
spaceship but we've seen the corn fields
so I think it's time to reposition but I
do think and I want to say on record
like Henry Cavill is the Andrew Garfield
of this and I I think when you mention
Spider-Man I think Andrew Garfield's one
of the best Spider-Man yeah that never
got to Spider-Man like he I think in no
way home he did and I would love if we
got to Kingdom Come This with Henry
Cavill I'd love it in 10 years once some
bridges are mended we can have them come
back and get like a real Superman story
out of this because Man of Steel is a
beautiful Visionary take on Superman but
I feel like he was always at odds like
how he perceived Superman is much more
like how I perceive Superman and I think
his Clark Kent never really got to be
Clark Kent because it was always in this
very cool edgy world and I'd love to see
a little bit more foreign
yeah I mean especially in the uh muscles
Department uh homeboy got very jacked
for that right
um I love the idea of him coming back
though in 10 more years I've been like
what changed around here
what happened a little silver salt and
pepper that's what I always liked about
Superman Returns the Brandon Ralph joint
uh like the idea that it was a
continuation of the Christopher Reeve
story he'd been gone for a long time and
just comes back and like the world was
still kind of the same like the weird
kind of like had that 70s past t-shirt
but uh yeah you know we'll see who knows
what's next but uh I want nerds to win
that's right right yes absolutely and we
want you know if this gets us more
Superman movies in our lives that's a
win um cattle did put out a statement on
Instagram after the news broke saying
after being told by the studio to
announce my return this news isn't the
easiest right
yeah Black Adam
he also recently shot a cameo for The
Flash movie that apparently is now being
scrapped by cutting it out oh they're
gonna cut that out that was uh like a
reshoot they were going to kind of
squeeze him in there now they're
squeezing him back out
um do you think when The Rock woke up
this or last night when he heard this
news he just like grabbed two boiled
chicken breasts swallowed them whole
just dude just hit the gym I would not
want to be in the eye in Paradise right
now
and the thing is he's working out while
simultaneously on the phone with 30
people yeah I would not want to be
anywhere in the same vicinity because he
has in this kind of reporting that was
coming out it came out that like you
know cavali was paid like 250k just for
the Cameo they're cutting from The Flash
I think he still gets the money or
whatever uh but the rock turned down a
cameo in Shazam 2 apparently oh wow yeah
I think I'm actually a cannibalizing one
of the headlines later but this was all
kind of like connected to each other
because this whole thing you were
telling me this whole thing was like I'm
I'm with Superman I'm not with the
little oh he didn't want to be an issue
with a second team he's like I want to
be with the top dog uh and now he's down
and now you're out and the top and the
child has two movies and you had one
yeah and that's a perfect segue into why
I think James gun's doing all this yeah
right if you look at the the universe
they built and and I do think it's
important to respect what got us here
but at the same time it's been uh things
have gotten in the way a lot like the
first movie comes out the sequel doesn't
do as well as you want bvs doesn't make
a billion dollars and it's it's Batman
Superman two of the most iconic names in
comics doesn't make the money they need
it too yeah and then the third movie is
struck by real life tragedy and then
they try to salvage it with getting a
director that they thought they wanted
and then they deliver a two hour cut of
a movie that I don't think many people
enjoy yeah and then the years later have
a bot-led campaign with real fans that
really want this thing but then it's
overshadowed by some of the negativity
and then they get a four-hour movie that
is is awesome and is glorious but is
only one half of the story that was
supposed to be told so like they've been
chasing this thing I I could see where
everyone's like what if we just know
because if Shazam and Black Adam are
also at odds like maybe just no and it
does feel like that's a great point of
like if nothing else and this is going
to be a messy uh journey to get there at
least like there will be a unified
vision for DC because it's kind of been
their last however many years has been
you know there's been infighting and
people with different agendas and like
the rock wants to be doing this and Zack
Snyder wants to be doing that and also
we have the Joker unless we have the
Batman these aren't bad I think the
issue is a lot of people have Optics
around shared Universe versus movies and
you'll see it on Twitter right now like
I've been on Twitter too much today but
like everyone's saying like the movies
next year are not going to be worth
watching because they don't connect
anymore that's so ridiculous spend two
hours with characters you love and have
the bonus of enjoying a shared universe
and so if you're looking back at the DC
movies they're very enjoyable
individually I like the DC films but it
isn't shared and that's not bad that's
not at its demerit so going forward if
you want to have it shared I think you
need a clean slate because when I
picture Hall h and there's seven actors
as the Justice League which is what I
think next July is going to be them
bringing out the Justice League I don't
know if it would feel as appropriate to
be like Henry Cavill and his six new
friends yeah like I don't know if that's
gonna work Henry Cavill for the kids
from stranger things
that that AI actor
that Irish guy I I do it we one day
we'll do a fan cast of the new Justice
League because it is going to be like
um so uh our uh our Canadian buddy
Christian unpronounceable with a super
chat we appreciate you is it too late
for Cavill to return to The Witcher uh
which yeah just to quickly catch
everybody up uh this third season of The
Witcher is coming out next year that's
already been shot 100 couples in that
they're working on a fourth season now
he has already left he's he was uh um
recast with Chris Hemsworth's brother
Liam Hemsworth and to answer your
question to Entertainment Weekly has
already confirmed this will not be
affecting The Witcher casting
um Liam Hemsworth will definitely still
be doing that role I think people also
forget that there is uh online Buzz
about which you know online was about
everything but Insider Source says that
there was like a lot of conflicting uh
what they wanted from the show between
Henry Cavill and the writers because the
writers are coming from a perspective of
TV where Henry Cavill is coming from his
perspective of I played the games so
like this is what the Witcher would
which is true that's my one note that I
always give the witchers I'm like yeah
it's not like on top of it and so they
it clashed a lot and he kind of him
leaving was also kind of his choice but
he got to do three seasons of the show
that's a lot of time in the blonde wig
my favorite thing this morning on Reddit
was that each of the different fandom
subreddits I followed they were all
trying to claim Henry Cavill like that
Marvel one was like can he come to the
MCU
for Henry Cavill now that his uh
upcoming Slate's a little cleared off
um so yeah we already mentioned that um
you know they also squeezed Henry Cavill
as Superman uh Cameo into Black Adam
right we just came out a couple months
ago
um supposedly uh the rumor is that a
Black Adam sequel has been cut yeah from
the Slate obviously to the
um consternation of the rock James gun
watch you're back uh you have a very
large they might not tell the rock they
might let him go film something and just
be like it's coming out so if there's no
Black Adam sequel the rock is down to 50
projects
too much free time I mean if he doesn't
make Black Adam too that affects season
four of young Rock I think you wrote
that in already like yeah um and now
despite the Superman news uh it appears
that the JJ Abrams tanahasi Coates black
Superman project is still in development
now development can mean a lot of things
that means they haven't officially you
know asked it told people to stop
working working on it we don't know what
that means that that could mean you know
they're still just talking about it we
don't know
I want a less boring Superman story
honestly that would be such a fun
Superman story and also different guns
willing to listen to a good script yeah
let's read a good script and I feel like
that script would be good
yeah I could feel this one is very good
I would love like a non-traditional
Superman story like a black Superman or
like you know that famous like red Sun
very yeah or Superman lands in Russia
like some just change it up a little bit
we don't know I mean Jim's Gun said it's
a younger Superman he's working in the
Daily Planet we don't know any other
details about that right like that could
be a very different vision for Superman
make him an alien that doesn't look a
human but like no one notices that like
that's green no one notices
um another whatever interesting uh
little Factory that came out of some of
this reporting a gun and saffron have
met with Ben Affleck about directing a
film an upcoming film for DC it sounds
like those conversations were productive
uh so it's kind of safe to assume he
will not return his Batman right this is
not him coming back to uh portray Batman
uh in Solo appearances though apparently
you know cameos have shot for upcoming
movies could remain in play right
there's some thinking he might jump in
Flash we're living in such an
unprecedented time in all this man like
okay so you think about like the
sentences you just said he's not gonna
come back as Batman might come back to
direct all these things juggling all the
things that led to this we've one never
had a CEO be as Hands-On and
communicative on Twitter ever yeah and I
love that transparency because it feels
like the opposite of the bedside manner
of what we dealt with with like Batgirl
going away that felt very unceremonious
this feels very ceremonial I feel like
gun is honoring things as it moves along
communication the Patty Jenkins tweets
things have been communicated and then
at this the same time we're also living
in an age where we've never in the
history of movie making seen a
successful shared universe end
ever but the only shared universe that's
ended was one movie The Mummy and then
like Marvel's done well and other shared
universes like Fast and Furious and
Hobbs and shark kind of connected that's
still going we've never had a shared
universe and so you're having to put out
a hundred Fires at once you're having to
juggle all fan expectations you're
having to like keep the people that are
you know buying these tickets happy but
we're all at odds with each other and
there's this tribalism this crazy thing
between like fans that want things to
keep going and move forward I think the
only answer was restarting because it's
just gonna be this for like two years
yeah I'm so pessimistic that I'm like
it's gonna blow up um
blow up it's more so I'm like yeah being
transparent is great until it's not and
no one I don't think everyone can that's
why Kevin feige doesn't tell us
everything so I'm like when is when he
stops is it going to be a hassle for the
audience his fans to be like why what
did he do and I'm like it can backfire
I I agree it's nice to have him be
transparent and constantly be teasing us
with things but I will say James again
you don't have to respond to everything
and you don't have to react to all news
that comes out involving DC right it's
like I I stand with I stand with
majority of his tweets you guys do not
come for me on this sometimes he'll cut
he'll attack someone and that person
gets so many death threats and they'll
have to like delete their account and
I'm like okay you're tweeting at like
someone that does not matter don't tweet
at them you don't need to somebody
yeah things there's there's opportunity
right now too for uh publicists and PR
people to get stories out because this
is all just like sources are saying this
like this could be like Affleck's team
being like yes they were meeting with DC
because now you've put it out there and
now there's like fan expectation you
know you can crowdsource what's popular
also I think it's a really good time of
the year like we're going into a quiet
season of News I mean everyone's
wrapping things up I think ending things
this year cleanly and then starting next
year fresh is smart I think giving an
announcement quarter one after we've all
had the time for the internet to tweet
at each other and then like resting and
then coming back next year and saying
like this is the plan have a fandom and
then at Comic-Con show the faces yeah
yeah we just put up that that tweet show
the children
since the um Guardians volume three
trailer dropped two weeks ago it's been
a slow Marvel news time so maybe they
are like hey we can we can kind of
dominate the news
um he did also James Gunn said we'll be
focusing on most well-known own and some
lesser-known characters simultaneously
that's a dumb thing to do that's a
definition
no no it is it is smart because I will
say like
a minute that the
the characters have been have gotten a
lot of screen time over the last 30
years right we've had plenty of Batman
Superman uh even Wonder Woman uh and
most recently Aquaman but like that
second tier right the the like like we
now have Sean cheese and she-hulks and
whatever in Marvel we have not unless
you watch the CW right we have not had
as much of those that equivalent DC
characters fleshed out that's not in the
God dang Gotham Universe I'm I I love I
love DC's villains but they're not only
in Gotham they're not only fighting
Batman you can go everywhere and I think
that's the one my biggest thing for
James Gunn taking this over is I can't
wait to see all the minuscule characters
and he's been eating them photos yeah
and those photos I think are the like
dead man and Lobo no one knows no one
remembers these and he also looks at the
World building right like when James
Gunn got brought onto Guardians that
changed the trajectory that was the
hierarchy of Marvel shifting like he
changed what Marvel's introduced Cosmic
Marvel right and look at how much more
successful way and there's so much
Cosmic now like it's like half of Marvel
so maybe that also like World building
he was part of that trust at Marvel I
think he's looking 10 years like he's
he's doing what is the right move to
build this up good for her and he's got
a he's got to thread the needle right
it's not an easy job though it would be
a fun job to have obviously all of us
would take that gig
out of here
you're gonna turn down Millions to run
uh you see his fans
yeah
but just just to give yourself yeah I
know yeah
um a reminder so next year there are
three DC films coming out right these
films are all shot for the most part
finished right we're getting getting uh
Shazam Fury the gods I'm sorry four I
misspoke Blue Beetle we haven't seen any
footage or trailers for that yet but
that's coming out we have seen a poster
that's coming out next year scene is
believing um obviously the flash
schedule for the summer next summer and
then Aquaman almost exactly a year from
now it's coming out next December so
it's finished well okay so we had a
theory these movies are made
um Warner Brothers
uh Warner Discovery needs the money okay
to bury any of these movies these movies
are going to make a lot of money they
need them to make a lot of money that is
a company that is Cash strapped right
now so even though these aren't part of
their long-term plan and like James
again might kind of wipe the site clean
after Aquaman comes out a Warner needs
the money B Peter saffron produced these
movies he produced Aquaman 2 and uh
Shazam 2 right so it's like they're not
going to bury these uh I guess this is
kind of like what Corey was talking
about
a these movies can still be very
enjoyable just on their own without the
promise of more sequels afterwards we
also don't know about the future of
Shazam or Blue Beetle
probably not gonna make any more flash
movies is that safe I think I think they
move Aquaman and flash and flash is the
last one and they in them yeah I think I
think Aquaman comes out in the summer I
think flashes December I think they
reshoot the end of flash making
Flashpoint reset the universe and then
your last appearance of some people is
in Aquaman and then flash wraps it all
up Blue Beetle gets to be isolated if it
does well they incorporate him and if it
doesn't do well then they let it be you
have your cake and eat it too Blue
Beetle they literally get to test that
character out I love Zolo I think it's
gonna be great but we haven't seen a
frame of it I think that's very
intentional I think they're reshooting a
lot of things to take out certain cameos
I think they're adding certain elements
Blue Beetle to make it independent
enough and then they can decide whether
or not it gets folded in by the end of
Flashpoint that's what I do I think
you've got all this dough yeah
I'm coming for you the big moment
happens in flashes to reset and when the
dust settles The Flash is now played by
Henry Cavill
suit
Henry Cavill let's do some real quick
fan casting okay uh no more with your
friend Capital no more Superman what's
he moving on to I want him I want him in
House of the Dragon there are I won't
say he's already got all that uh yellow
uh White wigs he knows how to do the
old-timey talkie uh there there are
characters that are going to come up in
the show that are in the book that I
think he would be there's several I
think he could play there's some really
good ones I think he could play he's
also English so yeah you can do his
normal accent he would be on the team
team black it would not be on Team Green
no he'd be on Team Green no he would be
on team black he would be awesome uh I
would yeah I think House of the Dragon
scoop him up man okay that would be a
big pull for season two I have one
really big one that I want him on if he
doesn't want to I have an another
suggestion my first one the boys put
them in the woods I don't need all that
let him get all that anger out let him
do everything
also like let's hear some f-bombs yeah
exactly let him be Superman he would go
nuts in the boys and if he was like
that's not for me I think you do like
some sort of peaky blinders
uh I love man from Uncle very very much
oh yeah and I think that he is the right
age for a certain Cavill Henry Cavill I
would love to see me at James Bond out
of that man I think he's the right age I
also think Amazon could use a bankable
name like him in this new bond that
they're like just gearing up for and man
from uncle's like an audition tape and
then the one I want selfishly is you
want someone to gravitas for this role
you want some with an amazing voice you
want someone that's big and sturdy you
want something that's intimidating both
mentally and physically you want someone
that's gonna be a box office name you
want someone that wants to do something
for 10 properties that is a nerd Doctor
Doom oh no because you think of Dr Doom
he's handsome but he's got like either a
Scarface or a little thing I I think
Doctor Doom the voice coming out of him
and then you Henry cavill's not gonna do
a one-off he's gonna be like give me 10
movies if I'm doing it I learned my
lesson I mean you do Kevin Faye is
blowing up his phone
here's my I got I got a couple wild
[ __ ] uh a
um Henry Cavill loses 75 pounds of
muscle and he's Reed Richards okay
we're talking about he's a legit nerd
and not this like you know Jennifer
Lawrence like I'm such a dork kind of
nerd like Henry Cavill is building PCS
and painting figurines in his house like
Jennifer Lawrence catches trays today
she can afford it she's doing fine and I
love Jennifer Lawrence but like when
people like that say I'm such a nerd
it's like there's different degrees here
um and like I think he is be we haven't
seen him play like super genius so it's
just different enough he gets to do The
Sideburns you know like I don't know uh
that that's one
um
now I know a lot of people have
fantastic is the Wolverine
um
I say I
I like him better
okay
and he is pretty hairy
will and he gives too much of this like
this bravado I don't know he makes me an
animal he could be Magneto he could play
I would love to see him as a villain
yeah that's why I was thinking Doom is
like I could hear him make him make a
wreck
this is this is inspired by his
appearance in the Mission Impossible
movies where he cocked his arm oh yeah
um I want to see him fight Roman Reigns
at WrestleMania let's go Sofi Stadium
Brandon Tommy and myself will be there
Henry I mean the rock is already gonna
be squaring off of Roman Reigns you know
what's going to happen now that he's not
got a sequel to shoot and like just when
the rock is down he's like I got a
friend down the ramp comes Henry Cavill
we became buddies yeah they rip off
their their trainers
no they're wearing their costumes yeah
capes and all and they just start
beating on Roman Reigns and then the
bloodline comes out okay oh my god
get in there okay let's get into some
other headlines lines and we might
Circle back to more of this great DC
news uh because it's fascinating
um we got a new image from Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3. there it is look at
that comic accuracy what yeah I was like
I thought when Brandon I thought she had
dreads and it is
definitely she didn't used to have the
Ombre kind of the two different tones
can you bring up the image again John
her hair she had more blue okay I think
in our hair I remember buying wigs for
my nieces those might be descendants
wigs I'm confusing for uh that but uh
yeah I think I noticed that in the
trailer too with the few shots we saw of
her like her hair was like very dirty I
think that's that's just the ravager
ships they got bad water there I don't
buy water yeah well and and no she uh
Peter's holding a Polaroid yeah in that
image uh yep in his hand uh and in the
trailer for Guardians volume three uh
Gamora there it is Gamora is holding a
Polaroid we can assume these are the
same Polaroids maybe I bet it's like a
picture of them or yeah
he was like trying to give it to her and
she's like I don't want it she's like
this isn't me yeah yeah I'm not her I
never took that I mean that's yeah uh so
sir coming back we're still talking
James gun but now James Gunn talking
about his current project not future
projects uh an interview gun said about
rocket uh he was just fine being an
animal and he was transformed into
something else he didn't want to be I
think that transformation itself was
extremely painful but I also think it
made him feel incredibly alienated from
everyone else in volume three we learned
a lot about his past where he came from
who he is what he's been through it's
been a difficult road for the little
animal it is fascinating because we all
assume I know when I dream about my dog
becoming sentient and being able to
speak and like shoot guns and stuff like
that I assume she would like that
process but who's to say she doesn't
prefer her current state dogs seem way
happier than us they seem rocket never
gave consent right he can't give consent
as a record they're not on Twitter
animals so yeah not fair yeah that is an
interesting way to look at it right that
even though like Rocky gets me this
badass Cosmos flying um you know
superheroes to be a raccoon there's one
to be a raccoon
um gold gun also had a lot to say about
the pressure and difficulty of making
the third movie in a Trilogy he told
Entertainment Weekly the amount of good
third episodes in a Trilogy I can count
them on one hand okay and we will come
back to this and we will count that
that's a true that's a true
statements because that's like a lot of
mine yeah basically there's the Before
Sunrise series The Ethan Hawke movies
Lord of the Rings okay maybe Spider-Man
I assume he's just talking about the
Remy there's only well now there's
because
maybe he's not counting that's a good
one he says trilogies because like I
mean obviously he's leaving out Die Hard
with the Vengeance but the Die Hard
movies didn't go on Star Wars
three and three I think he think yes
these are mean like those three are all
good let's so if one's bad then they're
not anybody think of another How to
Train Your Dragon oh honestly impeccable
a really good one right Toy Story but
they've gone to four yeah Shrek's gone
beyond three well I'm saying the first
three though were like oh yeah but he's
saying trilogies I think the third
energy he's he's telling the end of a
definitive story right oh that's true
and and most by the time you get to
three movies again unless you're Peter
Jackson doing the Lord of the Rings like
you want to leave it open because you're
like hey three made a lot of money let's
keep going you know of the original Star
Wars Trilogy right like we all love it
it's great but two's doing a lot of
heavy lifting yep Empire it holds a lot
of weight and then one is still really
great the third one it's got Great
Moments it's got rough moments also
Chewie doesn't get a medal yeah that's
the first one in that situation I think
it's How to Train Your Dragon before and
I think this is the ones How to Train
Your Dragon you know any other uh good
Trilogy well it's hard because I'm I'm
like oh this scary movie but every every
scary movie goes to five movies they
have like screams coming out with their
second they're just gonna call it scream
again right
Kung Fu Panda no the last one was not
what we call like the Cornetto Trilogy
from Edgar Rice wait what else John
Planet of the Apes the the most recent
Matt Reeves planet of the eighties
because I think what
is the third one was not I did not like
maybe it's the third one because also
for Kung Fu Panda I was like I don't
like threes are hard it's where the
emotional Landing is and you have to
have structured it that whole way and I
think James Gunn has I think the Adam
Warlock thing that didn't happen in one
actually worked out by happening in
three I think the way he's allowed us to
really have a mystery of rockets gonna
land I think the Love Story between
Star-Lord he had to go through the
trauma of discovering himself then
losing his father and now finding love
again I think that's all going to be
beautifully painful I also just want to
say whoever said Kung Fu Panda I'm not
coming for you you're you're fine uh
personal preference yeah it's a personal
problem Back to the Future oh that is
that is a good one somebody tell James
Gunn that's a good one that's a very
strong Trilogy I will say
but as a whole
um so and then he had another quote kind
of just talking about this film how it's
like uh you know this is where we get to
know the truth about who these
characters are and I like this part and
we Face the biggest Stakes so a quick
reminder uh the stakes were pretty big
and the other two Guardians movies like
weren't they saving the universe
essentially like how do you what do you
think he means by I mean we speculated a
lot multiple characters might die you
think that's kind of what he's getting
at biggest Stakes I think they're gonna
break apart yeah I think they're finally
going to break apart they're going to
find their own different ways and go
different ways and that's the biggest
stakes and I think we'll see them again
probably during Secret Wars and that
would be their first time having to see
each other again and it'll be like what
am I been doing they were defending the
Galaxy but even the first two the
stories were a little and so they're
like yeah Ronan the Accuser a plot
implied is going to go on and attack
other planets but he's really just
coming after zandar in that moment uh
ego The Living Planet yes he's a problem
he's got these things on every plane
around the world but they don't really
think about that they're just having
their kind of little battle on the
planet this maybe it's more implied that
like especially now that we're like in
the Multiverse Saga that like this is
gonna be devastating to the whole
universe also we land on that planet
that looks like Earth has been modified
maybe we're seeing the scope of how much
he's done yeah what the high
evolutionary has done and implemented so
it could be bigger stakes and this one
seems the most personal so I think it's
gonna be those the personal stakes and
the Galaxy
a couple good super chats uh match 143
saying put Cabo in the Jon Snow spin off
as Jon Snow uh no as a villain maybe
just so he can show up his sword work
his sword skills uh I mean too close
again even your um how's the dragon I
don't care uh casting I don't know if
he's gonna do another fantasy thing but
maybe it would be that maybe he just
love swords uh Sarah V said long time
list and a first time caller thanks for
calling in give me a Green Lantern
please
okay
making that crazy ass Green Lantern that
found his girlfriend in a fridge and
then like Kyle Raiders
yeah also when I immediately think of
Green Lantern I go to the animated
series not uh with the Blackberry
big as hell so I'm like yeah I think
we're gonna get Jon Stewart and I think
that's gonna be I honestly think
Comic-Con this year is going to be at
least seven members of Justice League if
you look at the timing May is when
Guardians comes out and that poor man's
gonna be doing so much press asking
about DC while he's putting up his
Marvel film and then two months later is
the announcement so I think maybe even a
fan dome in the spring we get Guardians
out and then July they show off the the
news I just realized you had two mugs
not messing around there
is mascar race has a good question for
you too said you would have a good
answer for this do any of you guys have
a good spider Gwen comic recommendations
I need an opinion from people I trust
before I purchase winky tongue out Emoji
after the Q a after party I think the
best one to read is the edge of the
Universe I like the spider uh with
spider Gwen with her dad hunting her
down as the spider Gwen because that's
the same relationship they're gonna have
in across the spider verse okay okay and
the Art's gorgeous I like and that's the
visual style it looks like they're
pulling from yeah edge of the Universe I
think it's edge of a universe spiders uh
it's only one so it's really quick read
and I'm sure it's on Marvel unlimited
for like 1.99 and then volume one like
the first six issues are like I must
read for her origin and the
relationships Peter Parker and all those
things so like that first volume I liked
it uh like her as a drummer in the Mary
Jane's the band the whole thing also
gwenpool uh gwenpool's great which is
this
a fun take on spider Gwen if she had
Deadpool's fourth wall breaking ability
so you get like that playfulness of Gwen
it's not directly connected but it's a
good thing she has too many comic books
because there's also another one that
has every Spider Woman in it so it has
Cindy Moon and it has Jessica Drew and
yeah it has silk and it has Jessica Drew
and it goes through all of the spider
women and they're always working with
spider Gwen and it's very good I can't
remember put the volume up too if you go
to Marvel unlimited and just do spider
Gwen and then just look up her hits
it'll show the top comics that's like
number two that's good good advice uh I
like uh deki Max saying uh Mr Freeze
needs a reboot time to put you on Ice
Batman yeah yeah but cavalin is free yes
shave his head they're not gonna have I
don't think Cowboy's gonna do any more
DC work for a lot of reasons but um
that's right we gotta find new
franchises for him the man must work uh
speaking of new franchises and people
that need to work hey you might need to
send uh Christmas gifts this year maybe
you just need or other holidays that's
right or yeah maybe we got friends with
birthdays I mean maybe you want to treat
yourself maybe you're going to get a
bunch of [ __ ] gifts this year whoa and
you want to make sure there's something
that you want Oh under the Christmas
tree so you need to buy it yourself for
yourself over that head over to new
rockstarsmerch.com uh we've got shirts
like this one uh if I ever see you at a
con and you're wearing this shirt you
will get a high five
um but we also have other fun products
like things that make uh stickers like
our Infamous uh thumbs you know so well
so you could take like one of your
family photos maybe uh this lovely
family photo you have sitting around and
you can point out little Easter eggs
like oh did you know we're all smoking
in this photo yeah you can be like
she killed my husband whoa
whoa you know do that to your family
folks your mother will appreciate that
this is way too exciting to play with me
yeah the circle's actually Circle okay
yeah
oh this is good too play games with your
friends okay so for me I I immediately
go like he was filming Mission
Impossible while also going Superman so
he couldn't shaved it yeah
how much for the staff does he know did
he know does he know does he know that
yeah
hoodies water bottles there's a lot of
fun stuff over there new
rockstarsworks.com check it out
um it helps support our Channel and the
goofball stuff that we do here
um we appreciate you everybody that's
that's heading over there we've had a
lot of folks reach out to us that they
grab some stuff there now I'm very
excited for this next oh gosh very
excited how excited
to the Moon do you want to introduce
what it is okay so uh Jessica did a
great job breaking down the spider-verse
trailer it came out that video came out
two days ago yesterday two days ago
we've got multiple videos on the channel
talking about the spider first trailer
but one of the things that stood out to
us was the volume of spider characters
in that trailer and because we have
particularly in the break room we have
Twisted Minds here we thought it would
be a lot of fun yes to play a little
yeah
in case you guys are listening on the
TVs
play the graphic
military five
oh I shouldn't be as we couldn't do it
anyway it didn't happen right oh nice
we're gonna play it twice
um happy birthday to me we're gonna play
it for three
and work out your core we're gonna play
for four that's like
oh don't ignore the core
it's hard
away and just like me I'm Never Gonna
Leave I don't know what your core to go
away otherwise you're just floating tops
[Music]
to play Bang Mary kill you guys okay
we're gonna play Bang Mary kill but this
bang Mary kills a little different okay
and how it's a little different is
you're gonna get your first bangberry
kill option okay you choose and then you
get your second one and you can't go
back and change the answer so we're
gonna see of the three we'll see one at
a time yes
okay okay no back seats we're gonna
start with Zach oh okay great okay so
we're gonna start with Zach it's gonna
it's gonna go off about here you have to
use one bang one Mary one kill out of
these three yeah okay and we're gonna
judge okay wow look at this graphic uh
producer dashel
bang Mary I gotta say Catherine Hahn
does it for me great voice actor loved
this character this is my
bangers you're not nervous oh what's
your second well you gotta you don't
want to marry her she's got a good job
no I don't she might be a little crazy
no I gotta marry him
this is oh my God you're gonna kill them
naturally it's gonna be like a child
it's very thick yeah that he would
die do you stand with your options you
know what I don't hate those options
okay for koi also in the chat you guys
let us know what you think
the best options let's see oh
spider wolf okay so I feel like
I'm a curious man look at how he's
walking though yeah yeah but the
commitment I couldn't do because that's
so much fur in the house yeah I have a
short-haired cat for a reason once a
month you give them the house to
yourself right now
sometimes twice a month in the comic
didn't he just eat a bunch of people
yeah I just feel like bestiality is not
my cup it's I'm not gonna kill I'm gonna
kill him kill him yeah
we're going there I just don't feel like
I don't need that heat okay
okay Miguel O'Hare is one of my favorite
characters
uh he's got a little temper though uh
he's a little he's a little hot-headed
so I feel like our marriage would be a
little tempestuous so I'm I'm a bang I'm
a bang man myself for 299
it's fine so this is the person that
we're gonna have a mother shocking good
time
oh my God all right what are the stakes
what do we got excited I'm excited who
am I marrying oh is that PS1 Spider-Man
yes
there are lots of hacks
I'm so bad those are
Owens okay let's go with me yeah I was
just going down the line I was going
down the line oh
[Music]
right at the top he's a cop
but you could marry a cop good pension
you know what I mean
keep you safe yeah well I'm thinking oh
he's still fine as hell that's a problem
I don't care uh he's fine as hell but
he's also a little bit of a helicopter
parent
I don't know miles got out plenty of
times
he's not gonna be your parent yeah he's
gonna be your spouse yeah or your hookup
or you killing a cop I'll bang them yeah
okay that's a good move
here we go
oh wait Mary
you're so good you're so good I was like
upset
you're gonna race someone else you just
got married look at that win okay who
are you killing oh let's see all of
these are really good options I mean the
spider fan so this is who I'm killing
yeah
I would have killed the first one and
married him yeah I can't believe it
that's why the game's hard I can't
believe it is ouch okay Brandon Parker
did it
oh fantastic
I don't you're definitely not marrying
this guy because he's too much there's
too much going on too wild I don't know
I want to kill him
all right
I'll take my chances all right
like a lot of great stuff you could have
free hot dogs whenever you want your
pockets are always because remember
you need a giant hammer yeah
the laughter the laughter you gotta live
laugh love oh
um
I know very good about it but uh yeah
I just want to say when I said that the
Deep could [ __ ] that octopus because the
octopus gave consent you gave me [ __ ]
for wow
so John we made it through this whole
episode
and then you come in here
the dog as a reference
the only one cat and I was talking about
fur the only one who says that the
octopus gives consent is the Deep yes
do you want to play
oh he's got to press the button he's the
way he's the one turning the wheel I
wanted to do another one it was real
that was excellent and kudos to uh to
John and to producer dashville for
putting that together that was a super
fun game we will probably play more of
some version of that in the future uh
real quick what's your uh Spider verse
porn parody title oh how do you put that
together
I mean it's still just into the
spider-verse right yeah yeah yeah
um
uh into the into the spooter into the
spider fur oh no yeah
it's a two-hour Spicer curse I don't
know um into the spider purse the purse
is a vagina okay I'll piss the spider
post
what did John do this he came in here
yelled about octopi okay we saved it to
the end I know uh Peter Porker do we
have any last DC stuff I feel like this
was like that was the biggest news to
break at the end of the at the end of
the year I think ever I don't think
there's ever been a December 14th 7 P.M
news break quite like because that does
effectively mean a hard reboot like to
me anyway yeah they're definitely like
finishing off what they already got and
then we'll start over I think it's
pretty safe to say if Henry cavill's not
coming back no one is Spider-Man no way
ho oh here it is Spider-Man no way home
Spider-Man homecoming oh
uh we thank you all so much for watching
hopefully I mean James Jones probably
been tweeting while we've been on air
more crazy uh news but tomorrow's our
last episode of the year that's right
that's right uh we've got some fun stuff
planned for tomorrow in our final
episode
um we hope you'll come back and join us
uh again check out Jessica's uh
breakdown of the end of the spider verse
trailer that's up on the channel now uh
Eric has an animation breakdown of the
same trailer that's also out and Mt has
a uh his own uh rules of the spider
verse video that's coming out soon uh
check out all the great content on new
rockstars uh YouTube channel follow
everybody here except for me on social
media and um I don't tweet I don't post
anything ever since
and uh uh have a great evening everybody
tomorrow last episode of the year yeah
it's true
[Music]